Greetings earthlings.
My name is Questlove and this is my wired autocomplete interview.
Aye.
I am definitely afraid to Google myself.
Even if I have to look for something I will type Questlove.
Cause I don't want to see.
So me.
Doing this as face of my biggest fear.
What quest love.
That's a good one. What is inquest loves hair? This is a good question.
I'm known for my humongous Afro.
I come from a family of chia pets. The more you try to cut my hair,
the more that it grows,
I think that people want to know is the object that normally is in my hair,
which is the Afro pink. I keep it there because, uh,
my scalp often itches. One time my Afro got me in trouble is, uh,
I went to the strip club in Atlanta. First time they made it rain.
$80 fell right in the hair between the CR the crest
of my Afro pick and my Afro.
And the second I went to take it to, to give,
to like the nearest person, like security was on me in like three seconds.
Like we got that. We got that. Even on my body. I couldn't touch it.
What does cost loves real name?
My real name is a mirror colleague
Thompson.
If I know a person of Arabic descent is asking me what my full name is,
I will say a mere Holly Thompson.
I got my hero Prince.
He cold called me at a studio once. So I pick up the phone. He's like,
hello Prince. I was like, wait, is this you?
And this is back when we didn't know if we were allowed to still call him his
name or not inside secret. He he's,
he's still at black people call him Prince because we weren't going to try and
pronounce that symbol. He's like, I'm calling you Prince because you know,
that's what your name means. Right? And then, uh, I'll say four years later,
when I was at a concert,
he was singing the song sign of the times and there's a really famous line.
Uh, fall in love. Get married, have a baby. We'll call him Nate. If it's a boy,
he knew I was on a blind date. He changed the lyrics to fall in love,
get married, have a baby. We'll name him a mirror if he's funky.
And he kind of looked at me and like I knew my date was room for light.
That's right. France. The example,
what drums does Questlove play a love week? Uh,
I started off on a lovely accent.
My very first real drum set at the age of eight for the beginning part of
my career. I went with Yamaha because that was like the biggest name.
But I learned early in life that sometimes like the biggest name and the most
popular name doesn't suit you. Well, I like a really trashy,
dirty sound to my drums.
So oftentimes like drum makers will go for these long drawn out stories
of like,
they went to a particular forest in Japan to chop down this
particular type of tree. That's like real expensive.
Like this drum is worth $90,000. We use this particular type of wood and dah,
dah, dah, dah, dah, I'll go along like, Oh, that's really interesting,
but I'd never play that stuff.
So like I have about 70 drum sets right now and which I
never touch because I want the cheap high school version.
Like I want, I want their lowest,
most accessible drum like that to me is the sound of America's
garage. And I like that.
What type of headphones does Questlove use? Okay.
So really it depends when I'm deejaying,
depending on what my hair situation is,
you need a sort of adorable set of headphones.
Cause I'm known to break them if they like stretch out too much or whatever.
So audio technicals, M 50 X that's the specific brand that I use.
They're high quality. However, when I'm on stage,
I use a custom in-ear mix by the one and only Jerry Harvey audio.
They are the best in ear monitors ever.
My favorite part of getting into your microphone,
customs is you have to get the phone, uh, put in your ear.
So it's like a weird feeling.
It's like taking pancake batter and someone just like squeezing it and your ear.
And then it, you know, I'm, I'm, I'm weird. I'm sorry.
Where does Questlove live? I'm a rolling stone.
I was born in Philadelphia.
I still have property in Philadelphia ever since the tonight show I've
relocated to Manhattan and the dawning of a COVID 19 and
quarantining. I've done something I never thought I'd do before.
I used to make fun of everyone. Every professional,
every author and actor and director, I knew that got that place, uh,
in upstate New York. And now I've become that person. It's not a farm.
It's not a ranch. I think my girlfriend likes to call it a Chateau.
It's an artist community. When I drive, drive up at,
I feel like I'm in the beginning of a Pee-wee's Playhouse.
Like it's like a fantasy land thing.
It's kind of cool where to buy the Questlove cheese steak. Good question.
At most live nation venues. And uh, my hometown of Philadelphia,
Philadelphia Phillies, my cheese steak is made of a impossible meat.
I'm not a vegan. I'm not a vegetarian, but I do want to eat a way better.
So this would have came out way earlier,
but I had to strike a deal with Amoruso to make the rules,
because if it's now on an animal or a soup bread,
it's not a cheese steak from Philly. I don't care what anyone says.
You can't put it on our bag. Okay. Be Questlove Supreme podcast.
I taught at NYU for about six years.
It was just 25 students.
A lot of my students are actually notable people right now in the industry.
You guys know Maggie Rogers use one of my students one day. Uh,
my manager told me like, well,
instead of spewing this knowledge that you have just 25 kids a year,
why don't you make it national? So Questlove Supreme is, uh,
my podcast with my friends and we just,
we just talk music and pop culture. And it's not just music. It's acting,
it's film. It's, it's everything, pop culture, politics and everything.
So you can hear it from practically anywhere where you get podcasts.
Okay. What high hats does Questlove use full disclosure? Again,
I like there's a very specific trashy, dirty,
unprofessional sound.
I like kind of like taking brand new jeans and really destroying them so that
they used a mourn. That's what I do with my drums.
And with my symbols, I will just get very, very old Zildjian cymbals.
There's a guy in Chicago named Sonny Burman and he does these custom
he'll take the symbols. He'll destroy them. He'll cut holes in them.
They'll just make them sound like trash cans. And oftentimes, uh,
I will use that, but the company I endorse Zildjian they have, uh,
a brand called, uh, FX stack, which is the same thing. They, uh,
poke holes in the, in the symbols to give it more bite,
more edge to it. So those, those are the symbols that I use.
What is Questlove's of vinyl collection? When I was five years old,
a complete stranger asked me what type of music I like.
And she brought me my first three records in a record player.
I found the note that she wrote to my parents. Like I love Amir. He's so cute.
I want to buy him records. And she wrote it on a cocktail napkin.
And I found that note like two weeks ago and I put it on my Instagram and I
wanted to find this woman, her name was Ellie. She lived in Portland, Maine.
They just found her.
So I guess I get a chance to think her because now I own 200,000 records.
She planted a seed that sort of grew out of
control. And now I need to buy houses just to step my records.
What quest love lost? I can't believe this is actually on Google.
Like I don't know what I lost. I, I,
I don't recall any bet I've ever lost or if I ever lost like
my, Oh, I've lost my luggage. Wait,
wait. As I'm thinking of time, every one on the side, like
I was like, Oh yeah, early 2018,
very dangerous morbid, uh, in 400,
like 15, 16 pounds,
a lot of people in my genre and whatnot,
they were sort of succumbing to strokes and heart attacks.
And I didn't want to be that cliche.
I want to live to the age of 90 and see my full life through.
I met the happiest I've ever been in my life. I will say that, uh, quarantining.
I know that people, uh,
got into the habit of panic eating and my girlfriend is not having that.
Nothing will ever be the moment when my band me,
they all put on like five pounds and I took off like 60.
So was a Questlove yacht rock. All right. Here's the thing.
My friendship with Anthony Bordain sparked because
of his hatred for yap rock music. When I met Anthony Bordain,
I asked him, I was like, is it true that you fired three chefs in your kitchen?
Because they were listening to Billy Joel. And he says, no,
I hung a sign up saying, I will fire you.
If you listen to Billy Joel in my kitchen.
And they defiantly put Billy Joel on. So I fired him to me. That was like, Oh,
challenge accepted.
So whenever we're Dane will come on the show on the tonight show,
he would ask like, what walk out music are you going to play for me?
And I'd tell him some like, whatever, like do some led Zeppelin song.
And he's like, yeah, yeah, some real cool. And then whenever he walks out,
I just played Billy Joel, just to get them angry. When he passed away,
I figured the best way to pay tribute to him.
And the way that really described our friendship,
like me getting the last word was I made him
like a 700 song, yacht rock playlist.
Or my Spotify is one of my favorite playlist. Like Jimmy, Jimmy,
Fallon's obsessed with this playlist. Like it's cool.
I dig it all yacht rock fans just know that I'm the King of yacht rock of course
loves favorite albums during quarantining.
I did this challenge and all my Spotify,
I put in order my 100 favorite records. Now I'll just tell you my top 10,
but all 100 in there.
So my number 10 is Stevie Wonder's music of my mind.
My number nine is a tribe called quest midnight marauders.
My number eight is 1999 by Prince number seven
is voodoo by D'Angelo.
Number six is de LA soul is dead.
Number five is Rufus and Chaka cons ask Rufus.
My number four is Michael Jackson's off the wall.
My number three is fantastic volume one by slim village.
Number two is it takes a nation of millions to hold us back by public enemy.
And my number one record of all time is person to person live
1976,
by the average white Google wait kind of light on me because I think
when any of my other friends do this, like it's the meanest things ever.
So it shows me that people might actually like me.
So that's cool.